[Music]
so sale Montreal is bringing fresh ideas
from South Korea I'm very excited about
the creation of sale which is a new
academic style research lab Pali located
within Mila which makes it very unique
we're hiring research scientists to do
open science in collaboration with the
Malenko system as well as visitors from
sate in Korea
what I expect is that there would be a
lot more research collaborations a lot
more exchanges events that will happen
that'll increase the amount of cool new
research that's being done by both labs
I hope that the collaboration with Mila
which actually started a few years ago
will will continue I think on the
theoretical side Simonis is an amazing
researcher and he's recruiting very
strong theory people but I think the
collaboration also leads to practical
applications which otherwise we wouldn't
have a chance to do
a lot of companies have studied the lab
together with a Milla's such as
Microsoft Google and all the other
places but what we see is that the toes
are all US companies only and then what
I believe is that the sale which is the
AI lab of the Samsung advancing sphere
of technology can bring another
perspective I believe this kind of
diverse view is going to be the thing
that's going to it makes sale really
great and also so I hope that we the
sale lab will inspire us to to bring us
do inside
[Music]
it's contributing to the AI hub in
Montreal the AI ecosystem is great to
have companies like Samsung that can
have a huge worldwide impact with their
products embedded in Mila
[Music]
[Applause]